Tom Verducci back here on the show how
are you Tom very well it just came out
of the John Carlos then press conference
okay
so what did you glean from that press
conference that you might not already
have known Tom I like this advice that
advice to Marlon fans hang in there you
know he made it clear that there's no
structure there every year is different
in the next couple of years at least are
going to be extremely difficult Miami so
listen this thing came about because of
the ownership change especially because
John Carl would have that no trade
clause it was one thing to get three
hundred twenty five million dollar
contract it was another one to have a
blanket no trade clause she turned the
Marlins were over a barrel and the
Yankees I think they got a bargain when
you think about what they're inheriting
in terms of money and the player what
they gave up they couldn't work that any
better for New Yorker so let's let's
take on some of these story lines right
here what do you say to the notion that
Jeter did this is a Manchurian
pinstriped and today Tom for the Yankees
no I mean listen this is driven
completely by money this was a salary
dump well you look at what the Yanks
what the Marlins got back in terms of
talent this was about the team that
would take on the most remaining dollars
on that contract and that was the New
York Yankees it's as simple as that
wasn't because they like the Yankees
farm system it was also again because
and had that no trade clause and
basically down to four teams and that
was it he wasn't going to the Cardinal
he wasn't going to China and so limited
feel and they found someone who take the
most amount of money that was the New
York Yankees
so is it accurate to say that the four
teams that he told the Marlins to go
talk to were the Yankees Cubs Dodgers
and Astros were those the four teams Tom
I believe he didn't reveal that list
specifically but he did say he did
mention the Dodgers he did mention the
Yankees of course he said the Yankees
were on the top of his list but the way
he put it easy to say now that he signed
but probably was true given the fact
that the Yankees now are ready made to
compete year after year for a while I
mean you're talking about Sanchez bird a
judge of course and Fenton will be
together at least assuming span dozen
opted out for the Lex five years at
least five years together all these guys
right now in the 20s you're looking at a
modern day and mur
Tom Verducci joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show earlier I said that Jeter is
doing his job to perfection Tom and by
that I mean the fact that he is a human
shield for the owner of this team that's
the pro at least the majority owner of
this team and Bruce Sherman that that
that he has taken all the heat of
getting rid of Stanton and a lot of
what's going on in the front office
that's really ticking off fans there in
South Florida what do you say to that
supposition well I think it's agreeing
you're right he is the face of the
franchise right now especially what's no
longer there and I think he's doing the
right thing in terms of baseball
architecture you know span got up there
today and he said listen I thought we
had a good lineup I think with some
additions to our pitching staff we can
compete
that's not how today's game operates
you're either all in or you're not in at
all you don't want to be in the middle
ground and that's where the Marlins were
for the last couple of years actually so
you need to strip it all the way down
and that's what they're doing here it's
gonna be painful the next few years so
as a business plan it works as a
baseball franchise you're a fan of the
Marlins it stings
I mean you just went through an
ownership and Luria's group before where
there was no connection with the city
you figure you get high hopes that guy
like Derek Jeter is coming in that
they're really gonna try the first thing
they did it was trade the franchise
player it's gonna take a long time to
win those people back both on the field
and off the field so let's let's let's
take a look up higher here then Tom like
did baseball not know that when they
approve this sale to this ownership
group that a fire sale would happen with
their MVP in the National League and if
so then why did they approve this sale
why would they say yes to something like
this well because they brought in the
most money in terms of prospective
owners the most money on the table
Sherman's group and I think they did
know that this was coming because now
we've seen the stripped downs in Chicago
we've seen it used but it's going on now
and some other places the White Sox the
Phillies the Tigers will be next you
know this is the cycle of the game the
boom-and-bust cycles that teams go
through and I think they knew I think
the Major League Baseball people knew
but you know listen they had a chance to
get
Derek Jeter involved as well don't
discount the market value of his name
and when a group comes to MLB and Derek
Jeter is on a massive the ownership
group it's hard to leave him outside the
door and not bring him in and I'm sure
the sex appeal of Jeter's name had
something to do with it but it was
mostly about cash they brought to the
table on the sale Tom Verducci joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show okay
let's talk
o Thani the hype is huge calling him the
the second coming to Babe Ruth and the
hype might get so large that we might
find out that Babe Ruth was the American
Otani so how much of this hype should we
believe Tom a lot of it you know the
baseball people I've talked to and this
is now just going back you or he was
available here as a free agent last year
or two I've been told that he could be
an all-star pitcher he could be an
all-star hitter now can he do both at
the same time at that level I think
that's where the that the question is I
think he'll be an impact pitcher right
away I mean he throws tops out of 102
miles an hour and I compare his stuff to
take it to Grom except he's got a nasty
split fingered fastball as a hitter it
to me reminds me of Cody Bellinger and I
just don't know that you can be Cody
Bellinger when you're also pitching and
you see a [ __ ] three times a week it's
going to be very difficult for him I
think you'll hit homeruns and I think
he'll be dominant right away on the
mound but I think in time I don't see
him sticking with this I mean even baby
birds have to give it up he said it was
too much do go well maybe he'll just
wouldn't drink every single little mini
was enough to take trains so to eat so
the Angels just added someone with the
stuff of degrom on the bat of Cody
Bellinger and one person Tom yeah it's
fascinating it really is that we have
not literally we haven't finished this
room anybody who actually started 15
games on the mound and started anywhere
else in the lineup 15 games it it's
freakish the combination of skills that
this guy has and the teams that I talked
to I took the most of the teams of the
seven teams meet and the final there but
most of all of them said they don't
discount him doing this because he just
seems so
laser focus baseball is everything to
this guy he's certainly not about the
big markets or the endorsements he gave
up essentially two hundred million
dollars by coming here now rather than
two years from now so they think he has
the skills to do it the mindset to do it
I just think physically rich it's just
it's tough you know the baseball here is
different the mound is different it's a
much harder firmer Mound a softer mounds
over there recovery here the travel here
everything is more stressful I want to
see him do it I think it's a great thing
the Angels now have two of the most
exciting players in baseball and Missoni
and proud they're a must watch as all
Yankees of course I hope he's able to
succeed at doing it
I just think over time it's gonna be
very tough physically Tom Verducci here
on the Rich Eisen show what do you think
of the naming of Jack Morris and Alan
Trammell Tom I liked it I mean I was a
guy I was in favor of Jack he's not
about as a player it's the Hall of Fame
I understand his er a is high I never I
never really bought this narrative and
he pitched to the score and that's why
his DRA was high but if it was just
about the numbers we wouldn't need to
vote we would just you know go by the
numbers and put people and based on
certain thresholds but there is an
element of Fame to this guy and it
wasn't just Game seven of ninety-one the
fact that in his era
nobody was close I'm saying nobody was
close to him in terms of taking the ball
deep into games start in start out year
in year out that's to me why he's a
hall-of-famer he was the ultimate maybe
the last true workhorse in Major League
Baseball and he did it for multiple
teams that won so I was happy for a guy
who got 67 percent on the writers belt
to get in here and Trammell I was happy
for him because I thought he was
overshadowed by Ripken during his career
I just remember talking to Sparky
Anderson about tram and tram was I
didn't think he was a guy you
appreciated watching him play one or two
games like some superstar players but a
spark he used to say he is a manager's
dream he did everything well
fundamentally well but at a high level a
very reliable player and it's nice and
see players at the 80s especially former
Tigers I think it's been
underrepresented
get that nod so I thought it was great
and you know what richness the first
time in about 17 years but this
committee our form of it has voted in
living players into the Hall of Fame I
think that's terrific rather than
waiting till we lose these people like
Ron Santo to honor them hopefully this
starts new trend last one for you Tom
what's next in the winter meetings are
there are there any ripples to the
Stanton Otani moves that are on on the
horizon
or is it they could just treat that in a
vacuum and the winter meetings are going
to go along as expected no I think so I
think especially the teams that were in
that final seven there needs to
obviously move on after not getting
Otani I think that you'll see the
pitching market Falls first the last
couple of years the market for hitters
is absolutely cratered and you see teams
jumping up for relief switching
especially Brandon Morrow going to the
Cubs I think you'll see more of those
guys going here at the meetings and you
do the best and then we'll see maybe
trades later on but I'm not sure that
we're going to see a great market there
want to watch obviously JD Martinez and
Eric Kozma to me they're the two best
hitters on the market and maybe two best
all-around players but I think that's
gonna be a slow developing market I mean
last year's Encarnacion and Bautista two
really big bats and you know it took
forever for those markets to develop so
I think the team I'm looking at now as
the Red Sox rich and I know you don't
respond directly to your competitor but
the Yankees now to me on paper are
better than Boston and Boston needs to
play today's game which is hitting home
runs I like it or not the ball is flying
out of ballparks the Yankees now have
leveraged that baseball better than
anybody any team in baseball the Red Sox
are way behind the curve in terms of
power so they're talking about possibly
trading at Jackie Bradley jr. maybe
getting in JD Martinez they need a
couple of guys you can call the ballpark
so balls in their Court
again that's directly responding to the
Yankees but they need to improve
last one in 30 seconds if you can is
Jeter there or is he not there he's not
here is that is that normal for the CEO
of a team to not be at the Winter
Meetings
well not for the CEO but for someone who
really is making final baseball decision
it's a little unusual that he's not here
at all sometimes that guy the point guy
on baseball matters will drop in at
least a day or two you know all four
days so but it's not his style he's got
a very different style as you know I
call it a detached style he was that way
as a player and apparently he's gonna be
the same as an executive Tom always
appreciate the time we'll chat again
hopefully very soon thanks the call
right back at you Tom Verducci the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience